Mind-melting theories about the Joker are
a dime a dozen.
When the late, great Heath Ledger slipped
into the perma-grinning psychopath's purple
suit in The Dark Knight, fans went wild with
theories, and one stood out in particular
— that Ledger's Joker is actually a war
veteran.
The idea was sparked by the scene in which
the character marches in a police parade without
rocking his signature made-up face.
Comedian and noted geek Patton Oswalt is a
fan who's in favor of this idea, but he recently
shared his own hypothesis about Heath Ledger's
Joker that builds off the "war veteran" theory.
Oswalt suggested in a lengthy Facebook post
that The Clown Prince of Crime isn't just
an ex-military man, he's also "ex-military
intelligence" — specifically interrogation.
After re-watching The Dark Knight, Oswalt
realized,
"[The Joker] seems to be very good at the
kind of mind-f---ery that sustained, professional
interrogation requires."
After pointing out that...
"'[Ledger's Joker] adjusts his personality
and methods depending on who he's talking
to, and knowing EXACTLY the reaction he'll
get."
Oswalt supported his claim by noting specific
moves the villain makes, like poking fun at
mob boss Gambol, digging into James Gordon's
isolation, appealing to Harvey Dent's, quote,
"hunger for fairness" and…
"[...] Invoking terror to Brian, the “false”
Batman; teasing the policeman’s sense of
loyalty to his fallen, fellow cops."
Perhaps the most meaningful piece of the movie
Oswalt looked into is the moment when the
Joker conducts a, quote, "reverse interrogation"
on Batman while he's at the police station.
The Joker wants to test how far he can push
Batman, and tries to coerce the Caped Crusader
into breaking his "one rule" — his refusal
to take lives.
A fellow fan noted in the comments that the
Joker "directs" Batman's interrogation of
him, as if he's teaching him.
Oswalt added that the Joker, quote, "constantly
changes his backstory," and thus creates a
new identity with each lie as he panders to
the person he's speaking to.
"To Gambol and his henchmen, he’s an abused
child (figuring that they were also products
of abuse and neglect).
To Rachel, he’s a man mourning a tragic
love — something she’s also wrestling
with."
By the end of The Dark Knight, Oswalt points
out,
"[The Joker] ends up trying to mind-f--- an
entire city and the city calls his bluff."
But that may have been what the criminal mastermind
wanted all along.
When the Joker falls to his apparent doom,
he laughs like a child.
When he's saved by Batman, the, quote, "one
individual he couldn't manipulate or break,
he's blissful and relieved" and turned upside
down visually.
As Oswalt points out about the duo's final
scene,
"The language he uses when saying goodbye
to Batman describing their relationship as
an 'irresistible force meeting an immovable
object' is the kind of thing an interrogator
would say, ruefully, about a fruitless session."
Just as Oswalt's theory concludes, it apparently
doesn't really matter how the Joker got his
scars after all.
And as far as any Dark Knight fan knows, the
Joker is still holed up somewhere in Arkham
Asylum, where he may or may not be crafting
new methods of interrogation.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!